bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj e lui il nuovo
testimone andare lo shampoo garnier
credo è allora ragazzi siamo ripartiti
con the forest anche se come non avere
l'ombra sugli occhi questo non ci ha gli
occhi praticamente già due fori fatemi
andare un attimo dietro perfetto ancora
sto piede ancora non ho capito di chi
era lei ragazzi hanno aggiunto fassino
di cose che non dove sto camminando di
preciso di riuscire dove la spiaggia
prima di tutto perché sennò è
leggermente un casino comunque vabbè
andiamo avanti di qua dove già oggi ho
già trovato civiltà ragazzi li avete
pazienza e imposti prega perché cazzo
stanno volando dei tavoli da gioco al
volume lo spiega senta lei perché sa
visto i tavoli che salde buongiorno che
cazzo corre ma non mi tocco il fidanzato
sei tranquillo
preghiamo questa è e sclerotica senti il
tuo ragazzo qua con te lo tocco è tuo è
cioè una cosa sei tranquillo magari
turchia lanza vita vale allora cosa non
mi attacca diversamente dagli altri non
mi attacca questa scappa tanta preso un
palo in faccia brutti attenta che cade
comprendere questo è un cappio posso
fare le posso fare l'arco riesco a
trovare il velista caldo perché vi
potrei incazzare luca non certo la
scelgo te che cazzo è mica era andato no
spam
mi sembra la carta casse davvero troppo
figo mi stai [ __ ] sensi dopo un po
non voi ecco fantastico quale tette di
fuori si mette senti malavati il culo
ogni tanto va beh salve sentite io non
sono stata io non sono stato io ragazzi
me ne vado perché è stato bello però mi
hanno visto però di tela salve che
dovrei fermo conferma fra mito segno
nuova migliore amico non puoi andartene
abbi pazienza cioè si possono fare tipo
i guinzagli io c'ho capito è che
funziona magari ci faccio il guinzaglio
appello e lo porto in giro dei veramente
bellissimo amico mio
però ti doveva uccidere ma sembra di
andare sullo scivolo meno dice vito
facevo io perché ne fossi cazzo sonora
che sono morto sono un deficiente ma
prima forte a cielo delle armi per
braccio una gamba perfetto
io io ho una gamba ragazzi cielo nel
culo come fanno da veri vanno la mensa
qua sotto come fanno ad avere i passò il
poteva andare via di quel prima
possibilità che si mette malissimo
l'uscita ragazzo uscito no cazzo è un
bug non saprei
colomba che già da troppo bello per
essere vero per un giorno
salve l'uomo che cadde da sophie ma chi
cazzo sei superman
[Musica]
braga ma sto tizio perché è caduto da
soffitto un tizio a caso nov io noi
gamba ea una gamba ea una gamba e ti
faccio il culo e una gamba e ti faccio
il culo se muoio mica se muoio uccido
se muoio tucci dopanti siete ma franco
bragagna
il mio piede non è abbastanza ho bisogno
di altre gambe rega sto morendo non vedo
un cazzo perfetto adesso vedo le sue non
mi hanno seguito ragazzo è impossibile
sono ancora vivo per miracolo tipo non
sono anche come sbagliato completamente
sì sì credo non ci credo ho trovato
perfetto ho trovato la pistola adesso
sono pochi che riguarda te lo giuro che
se mi trovo qualcosa davanti chi non sa
pistolato in faccia e se ricordate tutta
la vita in davis ha dovuto fare tutto
sto bordello per un animaletto di merda
che è scivolato da un dirupo fantastico
si può trovare una casa sempre
datemi la gambe la gamba la gamba
ragazzi ci ho fatto loggia veloce parla
gamba serve sempre ce lo fa non ci posso
credere
basta sono solo un genio basta come si
faceva l'arco ragazzi che non me lo
ricordo che l'avevo fatto perché mi
chiamo citola dio possa mettere la sa
cosa perché grande è la madonna capi
firmati ragazzi manco armani sono fatto
a fare l'alcol all'altro veramente non
mi ricordo era questo più questo più
questo cioè si è fatto ciò ho fatto la
gara non mi ricordo non so neanche come
ho fatto a rifare impossibile non mi
ricordo le frecce merda come ho fatto a
fare
ho sentito un rumore bruttissimo in casa
chi cazzo sei pregara lo sa l'aver l'ho
sentita io sono dito che mancano a volte
a [ __ ] 26 amica mia vengo in pace
ascoltami sapere cazzo
mancata di brutto sorpresa l'ho preso
ragazzi stavolta eccola lì perfetto non
mi dovevi rompere il cazzo se una
persona e non e non eri morta ci sono
dei flash non fatemi pescare un ottimo
affare
l'ho preso no no era la tizia perfetto
le piume ecco che cazzo mancava perfetto
l'annuncio manca un colpo e sta sparando
h
cos'è che non aveva forse qualcuno che
sta facendo un trasloco per caso no
perché non do fastidio ai ragazzi
facciamo uno scarto dei pacchi sud del
def ore sono state di ispirazione
evidentemente però non trovo piccioni
cioè impossibile dove avrei st pistola
per sparare tica ecco ho preso non ci
credono più
ragazzi non ci voglio credere non mi
ricordo ragazzi abbiate pazienza che
cazzo vuoi tu da ragazzino tornato o mio
dio che son riuscito a trovare la
spiaggia come cazzo ho fatto non lo so
neanche io no no no no no no no no no
rega ricasso un tizio devo fare devo
fare velocemente le frecce veloce piano
b dove devo andare sulla barca prima che
arrivi note devo fare le frecce poi
torno veloci veloci faceva tanta luce a
caso ascolta zia mimi dai una mano
perché c'è una notizia brutta livello
[Musica]
ok ma certo ma mai sembra giusto questo
tizio qua secondo me ha approvato anche
lui con le tartarughe premorto che si
sta facendo buio fatemi sarei qua sopra
che devo farle frecce ecco il mardon
gabbiano del cazzo sono quattro caccia
posso farne un miliardo ci sono i
gabbiani e piccioni in abbondanza posso
fare quante cazzo ne voglio praticamente
ok perfetto rai adesso cosa farai
katniss everdeen o anche i fermi che
sono mai stato messo così ben sette
ragazzi re che siamo pronti quindi
mettiamo musica andiamo a far casino
fatemi andare a fare il culo a questa
gente che ancora una capito chi è che
comanda e con la luna piena ragazzi ci
sono i licantropi ma c'è anche fa vj che
rompe il cazzo quindi devi morire tutti
pronti non me lo devi stare ferma perché
già sono zona mila di merda se ti muovi
son cazzi
anzi che avevo sotto fantastico che
hanno piano piano
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no mi incazzo sì l'ho presa
non c'è
ma do bastare che basta troppo troppo
altro ticket di sel verdi ma chi cazzo è
altro che han zheng è in festa e
carneficina
chi cazzo sei tu minchia ma che cazzo in
via massa bastava troppo forte basta
e ora avete bisogno di uccidere qualcuno
chiamate fa vj ci penso io ora ma basta
cavoli voi vogliono le botte oggi che
fitto e frecce cazzo muori [ __ ] è
morta no niente non ha preso fuoco la
perfetta
cazzo no no no no no no no no no no
ragazzi ragazze merda ok
[Musica]
lo so
c'è un'aura potentissima volta a zia ma
se per caso parente di goku non lo so mi
ha dato una botta come no sono stormi
che ho fatto a mandarmi dalla giù a qui
con un pugno se per caso freezer tenta
di invadere il pianeta chiamate perché è
impossibile ai rapper che ci siamo
negatogli di ragno fuoco ti do porto ai
piani fuoco ti do fuoco
sappilo è lo sapete io te l'ho detto è
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no piano coi pugni piano che ogni piano
o premendo il tasto per sparare però vi
interessano a sapere che moncho colpi
merda e questi che sono allora o forse
sì io lancio se non ci stai lontano vade
retro sull vade retro goku palco no
[ __ ] ott e brava zia braille bengala
ti fa ho passato la nottata più brutta
della mia vita tra goku tartarughe
squali e frecce c'è stato pazzesco
minchia se lo prendevo da dove cazzo
l'ho presa ma basta ragazza poligono di
tiro poi fa vj ragazzi mio zio andiamo
ma che cosa ma perché è ricco sta
succedendo
insomma perché spicco al volume se fossi
superamento un ca ragazzo è diventato un
esperto nostro cazzo di arco basta
mischiatti un self i due amici
grazie prima volevo provare a vedere se
riuscivo a fare qualcosa del genere
sto nuotando nella ragazzi questo vola
cioè una cosa impossibile
succivo nuotando nell'aria ok io posso
nuotare nell'aria e voi no esseri umani
luridi e speriamo le voglio provare
andare sopra quel tizio laggiù per
vedere se ne sa prendermi la ciao
ragazzi e questa terra vi andrebbe di
nuotare insieme se vi va dall acsi
vertente ve lo dico avete presente la
gente che vi guarda dall'alto in basso
io in questo caso sono così faccia bella
come stai ribadì di fidanzati con me ti
porto su una stella sono molto romantico
no mi stai guardate come si sta cagando
addosso cosa fa ascolta fermati che così
dai di stomaco è un consiglio sarai
anche goku però non puoi volare ognuno
piace per poter i ragazzi ciechi tiri e
pugni potenti c'è chi può la prima
questa continua ma basta a è rotto il
cazzo
la mia ombra che bella che volando
all'indietro fantastico ma che belli gli
squali del cazzo che pensavano mi
attaccano a detta anche gli squali
tettona di attaccarmi ma sono troppo in
alto bene ragazzi e questo è finale di
the forest credo non lo so che tipo è un
finale poetico c'è il personaggio ball a
pavimento ragazzi sono morto e sono anno
in paradiso non lo so neanche io
comunque ragazzi e direi che possono
chiudere qui per oggi l'aula presepi ne
fosse bisogno attento di farmi la casa
voglio farmi bene tutto però prima devo
capire come scendere direi che posso
capirlo meglio nel prossimo episodio più
che ragazzi se il video è piaciuto se
anche voi volete imparare a volare
lasciate un commento mi piace anche a
mangiare i paesi perché come noi video
trovata una descrizione se non avresti
gli scriventi neri ci vediamo al
prossimo vibo belle ragazze